hundreds of rescue operations are
underway along the french italian border
after a massive storm front battered the
region
at least two people have been killed the
storm called alex
brought torrential rain that collapsed
bridges and closed mountain passes
which has been hampering efforts to find
the dozens of people
still reported missing
hanging on for dear life hundreds of
homes have been rendered uninhabitable
after stormfront alex stuck the
vestibule valley in southern
france on saturday
an entire year's worth of rain came
crashing down in just 12
hours triggering landslides and causing
rivers to burst their banks
as rescuers search the debris for
survivors local officials take stock of
the damages
there are more than 100 houses washed
away
some partially destroyed or isolated
the inhabitants won't be able to live in
these houses for a long time
across the border in italy flash floods
have forced emergency services to take
to the air
to reach victims trapped by the water
communications networks have also been
damaged
complicating rescue efforts and cutting
many families off from their loved ones
tuscany and campania were hit worse by
the storm front
despite flood warnings venice was
largely spared from the rising waters
thanks in part to its new billion euro
anti-flooding barriers